[Music]
mouths in a mysterious forest and dizzy
is wearing umas necklace the teaser
trailer for under the sea a descendent
story has sparked a lot of rumors and
fan theories the short film might be
only 10 minutes long but we have plenty
of theories that could go on for hours
watch until the end to find out which
character fans suspect will make an
appearance if this is your first time
the things don't forget to hit that
subscribe button and don't forget to
give this video a big thumbs up if you
love the descendants luma returns you
can't read about the under the sea a
descendent story teaser without seeing
the same two words
boom us back it seems fans everywhere
have connected the dots and believed the
sea witch's daughter will make a
comeback at the end of the descendants
to Lula references Mao's famous line
from the end of the first film didn't
think this was the end of the story
did you this could be taken as a big
hint that Emma will be back for more if
under the sea takes place between the
two films it makes sense for her to be
part of it
there are clues about uma in the trailer
for the short as well
when dizzy appears on the beach in the
teaser she's wearing Emma's necklace Mao
recognizes it and asks dizzy why she's
wearing it dizzy gives her a grin that
some might call mysterious could this
also be a hint that the pirate is coming
back for revenge good to short give us
another glimpse of Ursula as well uma is
such a beloved character that fans
everywhere are hoping she makes a splash
in the ocean theme short music from The
Little Mermaid one of the most fun parts
of The Descendants is the music those
coral renditions of Disney classics give
the film's their signature energy fans
have speculated that The Descendants 3
as well as under the sea will both
feature songs from The Little Mermaid
and there are plenty of hints to confirm
this the iconic song kissed the girl is
heard during the credits of The
Descendants - this could be a hint that
more of Ariel's greatest hits will be
featured in the upcoming releases the
name of this short is a direct reference
to one of the most popular songs in
Little Mermaid it's no wonder why fans
everywhere hoping to hear these songs in
the short some of you in wondered if
Ursula might reprise her number
poor unfortunate souls what could be
more fun than hearing Whoopi Goldberg
belt that out there's no telling what
great Disney music this short will have
in store clocking in at a mere 10
minutes it's not clear how many songs
will be featured in the mini film rest
assured there's bound to be at least one
musical surprise in under the sea Mouse
fashion fans couldn't help but notice
mouths all too familiar look in the
teaser for under the sea sporting lots
of purple leather and spikes it appears
as though now may have returned to her
wicked ways and the descendants - Ben
reveals a thoughtful gift - now he
Commission's a beautiful stained glass
window of himself and the princess the
colors were carefully chosen to
represent who mal really is her gown is
a deep royal purple not the golden blue
you might expect careful attention was
paid to the green of her eyes Ben chose
to honor mouths magical abilities by
showcasing her bright green eyes in the
piece mal is moved to see that Ben
accepts the real her could it be that
mal is merely going back to a look that
feels more comfortable could the rock
star boot she's wearing as she walks
through the forest just be old favorites
it's not clear if the sudden style
change means mal has had a change of
heart
the films have previously used fashion
as an essential tool to identify
characters fan theories surround the
clues hidden in the very detailed
costumes perhaps this is simply mal
bringing her own style to auradon maybe
it's the aisle creeping back into mal a
herculean villain some of the most fun
fan theories are based on facts Disney
has already announced that Hades will be
joining the cast of The Descendants 3 in
a trailer for the third film mal finds a
mysterious blue orb of flame floating in
a forest the orb whispers to her before
she answers the internet exploded with
theories as to who mouths dad actually
is in the Disney classic Hercules Hades
is the god of the underworld the
temperamental villain is portrayed with
a constant aura of blue flames could
these be the same blue flames mal
encounters in the woods candies clues
together really mean that Hades is
mouths dad if some
have speculated that he could be this
would mean mal is a demigod and could
explain her natural affinity for magic
under the sea could give us a glimpse of
some of mouths unexpected superpowers
after all how else will she be able to
fight off the ever so powerful
umma some argue that this theory can't
be correct because Maleficent has made
it clear that mal is half-human she
often blames which she seizes mouths
flaws on her humanity but how could a
human produce that blue orb we can't
wait to find out
mal as a mermaid fans have been begging
to see Ariel and her daughter Melody
since the release of the descendants to
the appearance of Ursula and her pirate
daughter have fans everywhere longing
for mermaids
many fans suspect that the short will
feature an underwater face-off between
mal and uma mal is half human and half
fairy
how could she breathe let alone confront
her foe underwater
some fans theorize that mal may get some
help from Ariel and melody and transform
into a mermaid herself
the theory raises more questions than it
answers where were Ariel and melody in
the first two films why haven't we met
the beloved princess and her daughter
yet have they been living under the sea
how does Prince Eric survive down there
setting those questions aside the idea
of mal as a mermaid is pretty impressive
the mighty princess proved too powerful
for uma on land but which she fare as
well at sea would her tail be purple or
bright green if Ariel and melody do not
appear in the shorts will we see them in
the third film mermaid mal could be
precisely what it takes to defeat uma
once and for all
uma in disguise when under the sea a
dissonant story with announced the
internet was buzzing with excitement as
Mau steps out of the mysterious forest
she meets dizzy on a beach now
immediately notices dizzy is wearing
Emma's glowing shell necklace when mal
asks why she's wearing it dizzy hits her
with a mysterious smile rumours about
what this could mean started to fly
immediately fans everywhere seem to
think the same thing dizzy is uma in
disguise in the Little Mermaid ursula
transforms herself with magic into a
beautiful girl she uses this
transformation to try to destroy Ariel's
happiness could it be that Emma learned
the trick from her mother is she pulling
a page from Ursula's page book it's not
immediately apparent that Disney means
mal
any harm in the teaser but that smile is
undoubtedly mischievous no one knows if
we're seeing Ursula in disguise or if
dizzy has changed loyalties could dizzy
really be rotten to the core has
spitting it in auradon proved too
difficult for the crafty designer
everyone is wondering what that smile
meant and where does he got that
necklace we'll just have to wait until
the short airs to find outs
CJ in Harriet's everyone's crazy about
Harry hook the singing pirate went over
fans in the descendants to its mentioned
in both the novels that the animated
series at Harry has two sisters CJ and
Harriet's would make excellent additions
to any pirate crew is clear from the
title and the teaser that the short will
take place on and in the ocean pirates
are an obvious addition to the story
Harry is so popular that bringing on
characters that are related to him to
make sense an article from pure fandom
list the captain's daughters as
forgotten descendants and fans seemed to
agree that the girls deserve a spot on
the screen could the pair make a brief
appearance in the short and come back
again in the third film one thing is
certain fans love the pirate characters
CJ and Harriet would make perfect
additions to Emma's crew the novel
series the descendants have been
acknowledged by Disney as Canon because
CJ and Harriet are recognized as Harry
sisters they're possible candidates to
join the cast fans have Ewan developed
theories as to who Harry's mother is
based on CJ's appearance in the animated
series CJ has blond hair
one fan noted that the only blond female
villain on the Seas is Helga Sinclair
from Atlantis the lost Empire Emma's
father little is sad about his childhood
in the descendants - we barely even get
a peek at her mom Ursula Disney has
already announced that The Descendants
choreographer Jamal Sims will make his
screen debut in the third film Sims will
be playing The Princess and the Frog
villain dr. facile ear could the
mysterious voodoo man be umas father
fans have already taken to forums to
speculate the announcement that dr.
facile ear will join the other
characters seems to have cemented this
theory in fans Minds if dr. Kassel ear
is Emma's dad that would make the new
character
Celia facile ear her sister could
find out about a family she never knew
fans have already speculated that
Freddie fassl the heir of the animated
series could be umas half sister after
all
uma has that signature white hair and
Freddie has natural white highlights the
character is even voiced by the same
actress who plays uma in the films we
may not get the full story on dr. Faso
Lear in the 10 minutes short that's not
a lot of time to tell a complicated
story a film it really is coming back
and the doctor really is her father will
we even have time to find out perhaps
the tale will be told in The Descendants
3 Audrey's return before the cotillion
in the descendants to Audra calls her
ex-boyfriend Chad to come change her
tire in Sherwood Forest
Carlos reminds Chad that Sherwood Forest
is 6 hours away from auradon
Chad rushes off to rescue his princess
and we're left to wonder what happens
next
fans of Artie said they can't wait to
see the character from auradon go bad
and audrey has been confirmed to return
in the third film forum posters have
wondered what happened to her and
Sherwood Forest
maybe her jealousy was enough to push
her over the edge vain and selfish in
the first film audrey has already shown
some villainous characteristics it's not
hard to see why some fans think that she
may be a new villain could she have been
tempted to be rotten to the core
we know voodoo practicing dr. facile ear
will be one of the new villains could he
have lured Audrey to the woods was her
call to Chad a genuine requests her help
or was it a clever trap could the forest
mal walked out of in the teaser for
under the Seabee sherwood forest we'll
have to wait for the short to be aired
to find out melody if you're a fan of
the descendants you may have noticed one
conspicuous absence characters from The
Little Mermaid live on the Isle but
Ariel Prince Erik and their daughter
melody haven't appeared in auradon many
speculate that uma and Ursula appearing
in the descendants - maybe a hint that
melody could be next with the title like
under the sea it's an easy theory to
believe after all who is better prepared
to face off against uma than Ariel and
her daughter how amazing with melody
singing a song from The Little Mermaid
being fans are so desperate to see
melody in auradon fact there's even a
change.org petition to add her to the
films many fans have stated that they
love to see new kids in
Don that didn't come from the aisle with
Ursula's daughter's shirts make an
appearance
Ariel's daughter is an obvious choice
could princess melody team up with mal
and the others from our Don to defeat
Ouma has melody been living under the
sea this entire time
the questions are piling up as the world
waits for the next chapter in the story
a petition may not be enough to add the
princess to the films but it shows just
how much fans love her we hope you
enjoyed these 10 theories about what
will happen in under the sea a
descendent story
[Music]